and we are getting some breaking news
from Niger State TV is naming a new crew
leader and that is General Abdul Rahman
chiani this follows days of uncertainty
after president Muhammad bazoom was
detained by Presidential guards on
Wednesday let's bring in our
correspondent Ahmed address he's
following all of these developments for
us from Abuja in neighboring Nigeria
what more are you hearing about this
well basically abdrama and chiani is the
head of the presidential guards the
group that took over power from Muhammad
bazoom on Wednesday and was still
holding him as far as we know that's
what is happening at the moment but we
understand that prior to this
announcement by the military it took
them long to agree whether or not to
appoint the chair the chief of staff of
the Nigerian army or Mr chiani himself
which shows it underlines one important
thing it underlines that there is still
uh divisions within the Indonesia
Security Forces about leading the
country when we see the chief of staff
resigning now being abramachiani being
his Junior the culture and tradition is
such that when a junior officer ascends
the throne it's expected that some of
his seniors will certainly give way and
uh people will be watching this closely
to see whether there will be some
grievances within the military
establishment in the year or it will
pass on uh peacefully but again
negotiations are also on pressures are
also on to ensure that Mohammed basil
returns to power
and that's right Ahmed we have growing
international calls for his release
France is the latest country
unsurprisingly to condemn what's
happened in Niger in the strongest
possible terms
exactly president Emmanuel macron calls
it an illegitimate coup an illegitimate
uh change of government and profoundly
uh illegal and he is saying that when
Regional and international organizations
want to impose sanctions on the new
rulers in Nigeria France will support
that move there are also reports coming
out of Niger saying that some
International organizations are trying
to shut down operations in that country
because of the uncertainties there
whether or not this will put pressure on
the military to quickly return bosom to
power or announce a transition program
uh it's uh the next few days will be
very critical to see whether that
happens or not absolutely Ahmed that
latest report that you're mentioning of
possibility of international
organizations leaving is interesting
because quite soon after this coup on
Wednesday we did hear from the from the
military that the various countries
Western countries which have a presence
in Nigeria that they would be allowed to
remain didn't we
exactly we heard that but again there
are concerns things like that
um when when cool happens and there is
international intervention to try to
restore order or constitutional order
then probably you will find citizens of
those countries being targeted in
particular so if an international
organization is aligned with a
particular country that is hostile in
quotes to the new Administration
Indonesia then certainly its citizens
would be free to operate wound feel free
or safe to operate in that country so
these are what international
organizations will be looking at but
again it's critical to see how the
response of the International Community
to this new development in Niger is
before we finally reach a point to judge
whether or not they will stay or
continue operations or not absolutely
Ahmed thank you very much for your
insights on this we do appreciate it
that is Ahmed address live in Abuja